president Trump waited more than a year
to visit California as president and the
last president to do that was reportedly
Eisenhower back in 1953 Mexico is right
behind me and the current border fence
you can see is lined by lights were
about seven miles away from those
prototypes and officials are restricting
access to that area anticipating both
protesters and supporters of President
Trump and his policies anti-trump
protesters clashed with police in San
Diego late Monday ahead of president
Trump's plan trip
he's persona non grata right he's be
that welcome in California he's
definitely gonna feel it mr. Trump's
relationship with California has long
been a rocky one he hasn't visited the
state since campaigning here nearly two
years ago
those visits were met by protests
including one in San Francisco that
forced mr. Trump to ditch his vehicle
and hop a barrier then we went under a
fence and through a fence and boy I felt
like I was crossing the border actually
since Trump became president California
has passed numerous laws protecting
immigrants rights specifically designed
to thwart his administration's policies
federal law is the supreme law of the
land just last week Attorney General
Jeff Sessions announced a lawsuit
against the state to block some of those
laws California Governor Jerry Brown
lashed out this is basically going to
war against the state of California but
the president isn't backing down the
state of California is sheltering
dangerous criminals in a brazen and
lawless attack on our constitutional
system of government a rally in support
of the border all is expected later this
morning President Trump is going to
visit those prototypes and then he's
expected to give a speech to military
officials after that once he's done he's
going to fly to Los Angeles for a
fundraiser in Beverly Hills and those
seats are reportedly going for up to two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars each
Nora all right Maria thank you